welcome to part two of the dev bytes
series making apps beautiful in this
part we're going to focus on the spacing
and the typography of the list item as
well as the detail view to make it look
more beautiful so let's just switch to
our phone to see where we were up to at
the end of the last part and we've
modernized the app and had an action bar
gotten rid of the virtual navigation
menu button the legacy menu button but
you know we look at this and the text
isn't particularly well formatted the
images are an inconsistent size when we
go into the detailed view the text is
kind of going from edge to edge there's
still some glaring problems from a
design point of view that's what we're
going to look at fixing up in this part
so let's go back to the slides and let's
let's see what we're going to try and
achieve the first thing we want to do is
have a consistent set of heights for
each of our list items so we're using a
48dp rhythm as per the Android design
guidelines so if we look at where where
we are now this is actually what we want
to be so when we look at these slides
now you see that the the line items the
the list items are really nicely spaced
out and we've got some margins on either
side of the the detailed view as well so
let's look at how we do that in code so
switching over to code we've specified
the dimensions XML file we want to
abstract out the the values that we're
using as much as possible so we've got
an eight dip vertical margin which just
basically means that on the text views
we're going to have it department margin
above and below and so the way we're
going to do that is in this list item
article in our linear layout that
contains our text views we have this
margin top and margin bottom defined
with our list item vertical margin in
the the detailed view for the fragment
we are also going to use a margin left
and a margin
right and we're going to use that
detailed horizontal margin and that's
what's going to give us the spacing on
either side of that detailed view so
switching back to the slides and you can
see the kind of spacing that we're after
what we want to do is once we've we've
put those dimensions in we also want to
now fix up the spacing with the
thumbnails and basically what we want to
do here is eliminate that inconsistency
that we have from thumbnail to thumbnail
the way we're going to do that is use
the center crop attribute on the image
view and set the scale type so that way
it's nice and consistent from each image
to image the next thing we want to do is
focus on the typography so if you look
at the image on the left the fonts there
okay they're not they're not
particularly attractive you can see very
much on the right hand side that we've
paid a lot of attention to detail there
and made some some really good changes
so let's look at what we did there we're
going to look at the the two main text
views the top one is the the title and
then the subtitle in each in each list
item so you'll see that we've used a
condensed font and made it bold in the
for the title for the subtitle we've
actually changed the color of the text
so that it's it contrasts less and you
may want to abstract that out too and
we've also made it all caps the other
thing you want to look at is the fact
that with both of these we've actually
fixed the number of lines and we used
this property called ellipse eyes which
will basically truncate the text and put
dot if it's going past that maximum line
specification so it just it's just
presented in a nice consistent manner
from item to item so if we now look at
the detail page the other thing that we
that we want to do is make the author
stand out a lot more and what we're
going to do is use this property called
text color link that text color link is
actually a property on on the text view
and we've just used this bacon color
again on the text views all you do is
add that one property and your your
links will stand out but that also means
that we
to make that that author at that top
subtitle a link as well so the way we're
doing that is actually for that part
we're doing it programmatically we're in
oncreateview we go and fetch the the
font color and when we when we're going
to put the author in that text view we
just put some HTML on either side to
specify the font color the other thing
that we'll see that we're doing here is
that for the article body as well where
we're using a custom font that we've
shipped with our apk so just get into
our checkpoint if you see on the left
hand side that's where we started we've
come a long way it's it's a really
beautiful app on phones now so join me
for the next part for focusing on
tablets